I'm as eager to see it season 2 as the
fans are that's the thing right with
Netflix shows you binge them so quickly
and you're like wait what claps Jessica
Jones fans you're not the only one
eagerly awaiting season 2 et caught up
with star Krysten Ritter and the rest of
the cast of the Netflix series as we
gear up for the next chapter of the
Marvel Saga more I wasn't talking about
the food fans loved the dynamic between
Jessica and Luke like honestly Sula I
love I love me some mike colter they're
so different but they have something
kind of broken inside and they identify
with each other because of that and then
there's just like some magic that
happens as much as that relationship is
fantastic my favorite is Jessica and
Trish yes are you okay yeah I just
thought I saw someone I knew
no Teen Choice Award for you that was
one of the most exciting things about
the show that female friendship and at
the heart of it that's really what it's
about it's about that relationship with
her very best friend her sister and I
just love how how honest and real it was
I think people really respond to saying
I say my friendship which is not perfect
and you know they're never talking about
shoes or a boyfriend their own kind of
their own story is enough to sustain a
narrative and I think that's really cool
what are your hopes for Trish in season
2 because I personally want to start
seeing her on that hellcat evolution you
know it's like this uh Marvel world is
we're always sworn to secrecy and even
if I did know I couldn't tell you and I
and I don't know and one of the things
that I'm really looking forward to aside
from all of the potential martial arts
or athleticism of the character is
seeing her relationship with her mother
unfold a little bit more I'm so excited
to see what they come up with so writers
are so fantastic and to dig deeper into
the psychology of the aftermath of
kilgrave and maybe we could do a couple
big stunts I'd be down for that